hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm gonna be giving you
seven reasons why i love investing
in property i've been investing in
property now for 12 years
i've made millions of pounds investing
in property so i really like it
and unlike a lot of people a lot of
people make a lot of money doing
something
and then they keep their cards close to
their chest they try and put other
people
off doing it whereas i'm the opposite
i've made so much money in property
i've brought my family in it i bought my
friends in it
i set up a training company which by the
way
i make no money from and i don't take a
salary from or any dividends at all
i love doing it i love teaching people
about property i love inspiring people
to invest in property so i thought i'd
shoot a video giving you
the seven reasons why why i love
property so much so if you like my
videos by the way if you appreciate my
youtube channel i do a new video every
single day
please do me a massive favor and smash
the like button smash the like button
also if you're not subscribed already
subscribe
turn the notification bell on so
everyone down seven reasons right here
i'm gonna share them with you
and also if there's anything i've not
thought of maybe you can come up with an
eighth reason
comment it below so the first reason is
this
people will always need somewhere to
live
no matter what the economy is doing and
this is why i love buying properties so
much people say oh it's a bit risky
you know what could happen the house
might go down in value but the bottom
line is this
if you buy a house it's always going to
give you rent because someone always
needs to live in a house
and i remember a few years ago people
were trying to persuade me i actually
had a meeting with lord sugar and lord
sugar was saying to me you know
why don't you invest in commercial
property buy commercial property and
i really respect lord sugar but i'm
really glad i didn't take his advice on
that point now he gave me a lot of other
good advice to be fair
because commercial properties right now
are not renting out very easily in fact
right now people are buying commercial
properties
and they're converting them into
residential properties for people to
live in and i just feel like when you're
buying homes
it's a very safe investment because even
if people run out of money
even if people can't afford to do fancy
holidays and they're still gonna need
somewhere to live
they're still gonna need to pay rent and
if you own the houses
if you own the houses you own the
monopoly board and you're always going
to be okay
financially so that's the reason number
one reason number two is
because there is still a
massive shortage of houses and an
overpopulation of people now i'm in the
uk right now the uk is an island it's a
very small island
in fact on a globe when you look at the
uk it's actually smaller than it
than it appears on the globe because we
blow it up on our globes because of our
egos because we are great britain
it's a tiny island now it right now in
the uk there's a massive
shortage of houses and there's an
overpopulation of people
and that's only going to get more so
because people are divorcing like crazy
i don't like divorce
it's i don't think it's a nice thing but
when when there's divorces
what happens is one family suddenly
becomes two and then there needs more
houses
so people are being born into this
country people
are fighting to come into this country
literally
and not just this country if you're if
you're anywhere in the world right now
there's an right now there's over seven
billion
people on the planet that is scary
high and people are people are literally
freaking out saying there's not enough
space on the planet so
if you buy land and you buy houses
then there's only one way that they're
going to go down the line and i think
that's up
someone once said don't wait to buy land
buy land and
wait so that's reason number two reason
number three is because
properties hold their value
better than nearly any other investment
as well as producing cash flow
so reason number three is if you put
your money in
the bank the money is going to shrink
the money is going to depreciate in
value because the cost of living goes
up but the money stays the same the
money is going to become worth
less not worthless but worth less over
time properties is the opposite
properties hold their value and over
time they appreciate i love that about
property
i love the properties go up and then go
down then people get scared and people
sell i buy and then they go up again
so not only do they appreciate their
value and you get capital appreciation
but also they give you rent you get paid
twice
in property wanting capital appreciation
once in rent i love that all right
number four the banks will give you
money to buy properties if you want to
invest in the stock market
you cut you can't get a mortgage on
stocks if you want to invest in gold or
anything you can't get
you want to invest in bitcoin the banks
won't go here you go i'll loan you money
to buy that
whereas properties you can borrow
traditionally
75 of the purchase price you can borrow
from a bank
that's amazing and by the way interest
rates
are lower than they've been since the
1600s
so interest rates right now are really
low the banks are lending out money
which means that you can buy more
properties get more capital appreciation
and get more rent and also when the
property goes up
you can borrow more money against it you
can refinance it pull money out
and you don't pay any tax on debt so
capital appreciation you refinance pay
zero
tax i love that about property i love
that you can
leverage other people's money you can
leverage the bank's money
in property you can do joint ventures
you can raise finance love the
flexibility there's not many
investments where you can do that all
right number five
property is bricks and mortar i love
that
i love that i can visit one of my
investments you know i mean i mean you
invest in um
you invest in lots of things it's just
on a screen it's just on a screen it's
like okay how's it doing
i love that i can go and draw i can draw
i'm driving around birmingham and i'm
like that's my house
that's my house that's my house i love
that i love that i can see it i can
touch it i can feel it i can sniff it
it's nice
no one can steal it from you because
it's attached to the ground you know i
mean people take the mickey at me for
saying this but it's true
no one can steal it i mean people say
but the queen could technically steal it
that's not gonna happen you know you own
gold it can get robbed
you've got money in the bank the bank
can go bust sorry
in fact you save up loads of money and
you put it in the bank you know what the
bank do the bank invest it
bank invested probably into real estate
so if everyone tomorrow went to the bank
they can have more money please
they'll be like oh no we can't so and if
the bank
goes burst you're only going to be left
with depending on how much you've got in
the bank
potentially a small amount of your
savings so
it's not safe property safe bricks
mortar
see it feel it touch it sniff it
whatever you want it's there
no one can steal it it's yours you own
the title deeds i love that
all right next number six
you can negotiate to buy property below
market value again this is mega
there's a lot of investments where the
price is the price you know
if you're doing gold or silver or
bitcoin it's just that's the price right
now property you can say that's the
price right now but
i'm gonna find someone really motivated
and i'm going to
buy it cheap that's a great skill you
know the fact that you can buy it cheap
the fact that if you're a people person
you know how to network getting with the
right people
you can get massively discounted bargain
properties
that's an amazing thing all right lastly
number seven this is number seven
by the way if you like the video please
do me a favor smash the like button
number seven is this
you can invest money in property but you
can
also make money in property the pie
is big enough for everybody what do i
mean by that if you haven't got any
money right now
you can package a deal negotiate the
price down
you haven't got any money to buy it you
can't invest in it but you can
sell the deal on to somebody else so the
pie is so big you can
do rent to rent where you can control a
property without buying it
and make money from the monthly cash
flow so
as well as investing profits making fast
pound
and slow pound love that i love that you
can you can you can make money as a
property entrepreneur
and then invest the profits as a
property investor so
they're the seven reasons i'm sure
there's a million more
comment your thoughts below if there's a
if there's another reason that i missed
out something blindingly obvious that's
amazing about property
comment below if you enjoy my videos
please do me a favor
smash the like button turn the subscribe
button on
and the notification bell on also i've
done another video for you which i think
you're going to really really like
check it out right now it is here loads
of people have become financially free
as a result of my trainings and if you
want to hear their stories you can check
them out right here
and please give me a massive favor and
subscribe right here
appreciate it see you next time